حلقه جديده من المقاس المتواليه التي
تواجه السوريين شكلها زلزال امس ففي
مخيمات يرتجف ساكنها من برد قارس ويعيشون
في خيم لا ترد عنهم صقيع الشتاء تحاول فرق
الطوارئ في جميع انحاء المنطقه المنكوبه
الاستجابه بسرعه والحفره بادوات بسيطه تحت
المطر وفي ظل اجواء بارده لكن حجم الدمار
كان اكبر من امكانيات عمال الانقاذ الذين
اعتادوا على التعامل مع المباني المنهاره
جراء غارات النظام السوري بحسب صحيفه
نيوربايز الامريكيه ففي مناطق شمال ريف
حلب التي لا تخضع لسيطره النظام اوضح
الكثير من الاهالي انهم يخشون البقاء في
مباني قد تنهار في اي لحظه وانهم يفضلون
البقاء في سيارات في اماكن مفتوحه اما
المستشفيات فكان الزمن عاد بها الى سنوات
القتال والقصف حيث اقتضت بالمرضى الذين
يتشاركون الاسره في حين انتشر الاطباء في
كل زاويه وركنان لمعالجه الضحايا